not the opinion of others that bother me
it's the opinion of myself so are there
any strategies for blocking out the
negative opinion oneself can have about
themselves absolutely either your mother
or your father put that negative opinion
about yourself in your head once you
realize that that's true then you stop
[__] on yourself and realize
somebody else made you do that and you
start the process of loving
yourself we are not born to think we
suck it is instilled in the insecurities
or negativities of the people around us
and by the way this doesn't mean you
should hate your parents they were doing
that because that happened to them but
you need to understand that that voice
is not in your head attention is the
number one
asset